[Música]
spectrum
recientemente recibía una capacitación
en materia de políticas públicas por
parte de una persona que ha trabajado en
el sistema educativo nacional durante
una gran cantidad de años se nos
comparte información muy interesante
acerca de los procesos de implementación
y evaluación que siguen estos cursos de
acción sin embargo lo que más me llamó
fue una anécdota que se nos contó acerca
de las evaluaciones periódicas que se
hacen al sistema educativo nacional un
ejemplo de estas son los exámenes tipo
enlace que son pruebas que se aplican a
la mayor cantidad de estudiantes de los
niveles básicos para determinar cuál es
el nivel académico en términos generales
resulta hacer que en las últimas
ediciones las comunidades urbanas han
salido muy por encima de las comunidades
rurales en cuanto a respuestas correctas
en dichos exámenes en primera instancia
pareciera que este hecho no es tan raro
no está fuera de lo común
pero es curioso observar que las
respuestas incorrectas que marcarán los
alumnos de las comunidades rurales o
indígenas eran similares entre sí es
decir estaban cometiendo los mismos
errores
así mi mentor se puso a revisar pregunta
por pregunta para averiguar cuáles eran
los patrones o quizás determinar cuáles
eran los motivos por los cuales los
alumnos de escuelas rurales cometían los
mismos errores
se dio cuenta de algo muy importante
hubo una pregunta que le llamó en
especial atención y decía de esta manera
juan tiene un corral en el cual se
encuentran diez ovejas un mal día a juan
se le olvida cerrar dicho corral por lo
tanto se le escapan tres ovejas cuántas
ovejas le quedan a juan dentro del
corral este suena a un problema
matemático bastante sencillo de resolver
podríamos coincidir en que la respuesta
correcta es siete ovejas porque si
tenemos diez ovejas en el corral dejamos
abierta la puerta y se nos escapan tres
ovejas entonces nos quedarían siete
dentro de dicho corral un profesor de
matemáticas podría asegurar que la
respuesta correcta es 7
pero no los niños indígenas y de
comunidades rurales estos estudiantes
aseguraban que la respuesta era 0 que
estaba pasando como es que pasaron de
entender un 7 como la respuesta correcta
a percibir un 0 es que acaso los
maestros rurales hacen un pésimo trabajo
o los materiales didácticos tienen este
tipo de errores que confunde a los
estudiantes la verdad es que ambas
posibles causas son bastante improbables
más aún considerando que fue un examen
realizado a nivel nacional
y mi mentor se interesó tanto en el tema
que empezó a asistir a las comunidades
rurales e indígenas que estuvieran
cercanas a la ciudad de mexico
una vez en ellas empezó a hacer
entrevistas tanto a los alumnos como a
los padres de familia para ver qué
pensaban sobre esta respuesta y más aún
si ellos consideraban que la respuesta
era cero porque porque es cero en lugar
de siete
lo que le respondían era bastante
impresionante resulta ser que los niños
dentro de estas comunidades están
acostumbrados a ver corrales viven entre
ellos algunos los tienen en sus propias
casas se dedican a eso
entonces saben perfectamente que si el
dueño de alguno de estos corrales olvida
cerrar la puerta todos los animales se
van a intentar salir todos no solo tres
tías y un ser humano se interponga e
intente calmarlos la verdad es que no
hay mucho que hacer en ese preciso
momento porque así actúa la naturaleza
es la inercia de dentro de la conducta
que tienen estos animales entonces era
imposible que la respuesta fuera 7
porque al final del día todas las ovejas
se hubieran escapado
lo importante de esta anécdota es
percibir como las evaluaciones
educativas en muchas ocasiones no
contemplan los diferenciadores
culturales o regionales que en buena
parte definen el sistema educativo
nacional como un todo
así la construcción de los programas
educativos debe realizarse de una forma
horizontal en la cual la mayor cantidad
de actores posibles se involucren y
tengan una opinión porque si los
programas educativos se siguen
construyendo como hasta ahora de arriba
hacia abajo o del centro hacia la
periferia se va a continuar con este
tipo de sesgos
citando algunos autores académicos
dentro de las ciencias sociales como
giovanni sartori se debe comparar lo
equiparable mente comparable entonces
no se debe considerar que la educación
impartida en oaxaca deba ser exactamente
igual a la impartida en aguascalientes
por poner un ejemplo de entrada porque
la extensión territorial es distinta y
asimismo la cantidad de población
indígena presente en una y en otra
entidad es diferente
debe ser diferente la educación que se
imparta
nuevamente considerando la mayor
cantidad de actores posibles en los
órdenes que el que más se pueda puede
ser federal local municipal entre otros
según el instituto nacional para la
evaluación de la educación la deserción
escolar y otras problemáticas relativas
a la educación nacional se acrecientan
en las comunidades rurales más que en
las comunidades urbanas y causas de ello
hay muchas
yo voy a considerar las dos más
importantes primero hay muy poco apoyo a
las escuelas rurales en materia de
artículos como lo pueden ser borradores
pizarrones plumones hojas de papel entre
otros
asimismo las capacitaciones a los
profesores rurales suelen ser
ineficientes y de poco acceso y el
segundo punto es que las comunidades
indígenas sienten poca atracción por
seguir una vida académica tal como la
define el sistema educativo nacional
sobre el primer punto mencionado la
solución parece bastante evidente es un
tema de gestión dar más apoyos y mejores
capacitaciones se presenta como una
solución ideal mientras que al tratar el
segundo problema se requiere un análisis
más profundo pues no es tan sencillo
entender por qué estas comunidades
indígenas o rurales no se sienten
atraídas a la vida académica dentro de
mi experiencia como estudiante de
ciencia política me he dado cuenta de
dos factores esto gracias a un proyecto
de investigación que estoy llevando a
cabo con relación a las comunidades
indígenas en mexico
y las mejoras que se pueden hacer en sus
condiciones de vida
el primer punto de que me ha dado cuenta
es que incluso en la actualidad en pleno
siglo 21 persisten ideales dentro de la
academia de las ciencias sociales que
perciben a las comunidades indígenas
como un obstáculo para alcanzar la
modernidad y esto no es una teoría
conspirativa es un hecho altamente
comprobable al observar los estudios o
las ideas que desarrollan autores como
samuel huntington quien establece a la
sociedad estadounidense como la ideal
como la que todas las naciones sin
excepción deben alcanzar y para ello se
deben eliminar los diferenciadores
culturales la influencia de este tipo de
ideas es tal que las políticas públicas
implementadas no sólo en educación sino
en todos los ámbitos del bienestar
social se orientan a cumplir con esto de
parecernos cada vez más a las sociedades
desarrolladas a las sociedades
otro ejemplo dentro de la educación se
da con los programas enfocados
principalmente en la enseñanza del
español es decir el español es muy
importante en nuestro país para
comunicarnos de forma horizontal pero no
es lo único que se les debería enseñar a
estas comunidades indígenas el segundo
punto de lo que me he dado cuenta a lo
largo de mi investigación es que las
comunidades indígenas por sí mismas son
extraordinarias son de los pocos pueblos
alrededor del mundo que se pueden
considerar autosustentables en materia
ecológica asimismo a pesar de las
intervenciones de los colonialismos
del alto mestizaje que ha ocurrido en
zonas como latinoamérica siguen
existiendo ya han logrado heredar su
cultura de generación en generación
hasta la actualidad es un dato
verdaderamente impresionante ahora bien
queda mucho por hacer para construir
esta sociedad horizontal de la que tanto
les he hablado para ello nos sirven los
principios intercultural istas que se
entienden como aquellos preceptos que
tienen como interés principal regular
las relaciones humanas
no anteponer una cultura sobre otra sino
igualar las en condiciones
resignificar lo que representa ser un
ser humano y algunos ejemplos de
principios interculturales serían estos
cuatro el diálogo horizontal trabajo
colaborativo respeto a la tolerancia
respeto a la diversidad cultural y el
último es tolerancia a dicha diversidad
cultural el tercero y el cuarto se
encuentran bastante conectados entre sí
es difícil ubicar un origen de la
corriente intercultural lista sin
embargo en el caso mexicano tenemos a la
gran intercultural lista silvia makers
quien ha trabajado el tema educativo
durante toda su vida profesional y nos
menciona como al construir una identidad
nacional no solo en el caso de méxico
sino en la mayor cantidad de los países
alrededor del mundo debemos tomar en
cuenta las diferenciaciones culturales
no como un obstáculo o no como algo que
hay que erradicar como nos propone
samuel huntington sino como algo que nos
ayuda a diferenciarnos como algo que nos
nutre que nos da una identidad más
fuerte y que nos puede permitir
desarrollar valores como la empatía o la
tolerancia de la que ya les he hablado
con anterioridad
es un paso bastante revolucionario en la
construcción de sociedades con miras
hacia un futuro de igualdad de
condiciones
ahora bien yo sé que no todos tenemos
acceso a los puestos de poder no los
vamos a tener pero seguimos siendo
ciudadanos y tenemos el poder de nuestra
voz tenemos distintos mecanismos como
las manifestaciones o el voto en sí
mismo y los invito a que reflexionen
sobre estos puntos la próxima vez que
tomen una decisión electoral o política
muchas gracias